[Music]
and Karma's a [ __ ] News so many by I
love said I just do my a couple wait we
love to thank you for loving my husband
wins a 9 million dollar lawsuit against
the man who had an affair with his wife
this guy maybe did some kind of damages
that that hurt his business or his
income how come the wife's didn't get in
trouble for anything all right
am I on the right track yeah oh yeah
part of it yeah see you next video
what the [ __ ] what are you pressing on
the next video I don't care that you
[ __ ] my wife
well you [ __ ] up my business man and
you don't [ __ ] with my business that's a
good angle of thing yeah because the
wife was an employee of the business to
which affected a lot of things so this
man the husband he owns a BMX bike stunt
a show that's cool that's super sick
Margie cheer on him and he's really cool
yeah so they've been married since 2010
I bet you they're sponsored by Monster
Energy Drink again TIA
i guaran-damn-tee is BMX bikes and
monster they're like I'm married let's
the other one that you drink Rock sir
maybe it could be I don't see it on a
lot of stuff like Rockstar sponsors
parties like like big events and parties
yeah I kind of see it there alright so
they have a five-year-old daughter and
so the judge awarded this ex-husband
eight point eight million dollars and
would have come up well though that
didn't bother now what is that money cuz
it's pointless if you [ __ ] like sue a
broke homeless man like nine million
dollars and getting the judgment you are
awarded nine million dollars from his
homeless man right here yeah auctioneer
tune and you're like well great I'll
never see this money in my life list
even suing me you can't even get that
much from me
just look even the billionaires in the
world they're not cash rich they don't
have cash billions people always think
that she'll musk you know like when you
made money from pipe I'll he gave all
that [ __ ] back into his other business
was it Tesla or some other one
100% and he was living on nothing so
everyone thinks like I'm doing Billy
iners have billions of dollars in cash
that's not how does he was already rich
when he sold the PayPal stuff to do the
Tesla stuff it's like your ass that rich
okay guys mm-hmm that means it's pretend
money that means like people go mmm I
think your life worth this much because
all the things you do
okay so Keith and Daniel are the married
couple Francisco is the Sancho cheating
there's a side dude word that's cool
that term from century yeah yeah is that
what I gotcha was just like one Mexican
dude no punk-ass I was like oh I thought
Such it was like a bully like I don't
like you Sancho what's it what's a Maria
yeah yeah I don't know crystal sublime
song no I know so blah I know the song I
don't know what to do anyway so the why
Danielle Mets Francisco at one of the
BMX shows because he was working with
some bank or insurance or something
something money related at one of the
events and so he's got satchel no this
is the husband Oh Keith and Danielle and
then this is essentially looks like a
Sancho he likes to hike on that's her
again yeah looks a completely different
I could tell by her gums it's the same
but then you could do it back and forth
she's blonde but I know it's her yeah
that's true that goemon smiles in the
way at the bottom that covers it - I
don't know why everyone's I feel like
that enough we'll see you guys I don't
know what your gums look like she's all
gums did this year gums no I can't yeah
okay no I don't know mm-hmm just smile
oh that's it smile all the time oh yeah
like this see your gums TIFF do your
best ball Vicky impression you'll see
all gums like this tasty got some sexy
gums all right so we met there right and
then that's where the affair started and
there were moments so apparently she
would break off the affair look I can't
do it no mom it's not right neither but
I need to well that's why I keep Sethe
claiming that like she would persuade
her like seduce her to still like
remember that time when we shared a
[ __ ] monster energy much so before
they split up she leased an apartment
with Francisco and keep didn't find out
until afterwards she ended up moving out
after they got separated and then she
called him over to fix something and
that's when he arrived and found out
that Francisco was there and now I'm
gonna show you guys a video clips on
Airbnb dude [ __ ] that's crazy that's
grand it's a harrowing confrontation
between a man his wife and her lover
she's my wife it's almost painful to
watch as 48 year old Keith King
struggles with his wife's lover as he
pleased with her to come home who's
recording now this bitter love triangle
has led to a shocking quarter oh that's
so sad [ __ ] the way he's acting - it
makes me feel so bad I can't even do
that
like even if I want I have too much
pride yeah I'll be like that's right
I'll cut you [ __ ] I [ __ ] do it all
along I mean he'd go home and cry yeah I
go home alright that's right
have fun with your new lover [ __ ] and
then I go home I'm like that's me man
[ __ ] I have too much pride dude
absolutely so the sideshow
too tough you guys need to come and hug
me [ __ ] and in the center was like well
my name is on the lease
yeah I'll get entitled to the [ __ ]
[ __ ] situation so how did he [ __ ] up
his business oh because she was an
employee and like with all this distress
of the because of her feelings well it
says that the company's revenue dropped
from nearly 400,000 and 2015 to about
125,000 and 2000 body because of the
distress caused the Sancho you like that
word quarterly the judgement hell yeah
it's part of my joke out now
alright I'm gonna give you guys a
proposition okay okay you might hate me
for this but I gotta say it because it's
just in my brain and it has to come out
so in this case wait you're eating
ground again this bridge is not worth
nine million dollars no no no this case
okay so in this case so she because of
the Sancho [ __ ] up her feelings right
it destroyed the business for both of
them but what if the opposite was true
what if a Sancho came along you [ __ ]
her so good that the business went
really good and then does everyone does
he get to benefit this time or does he
[ __ ] her so good she works harder at
work yeah that makes no sense let me so
in this case right in this case Sancho
has to pay money because he ruined the
business wait I know you're saying
you're saying that because he had sex
was still good and she's orgasm incoming
so good and so hard then when she gets
to work she's more productive what if
that was true so then money goes to him
is what you're saying
yes money should go to the Sancho
because he's clean how to play now
Sancho sues but that's not what happened
though wouldn't that's not what happened
I know yes I'm with you Keith is 15
years older than his wife and kids you
guys were wondering so she's been using
him this whole time so according to a
centrist attorney keep would control her
access to money manipulate her low
self-esteem brought porn into the
relationship with general with them I
mean look through her phone every other
week it's got nothing put her to work
without pay
and continued to schedule shows after
she said it was too much work and she
needed help with her daughter he would
track her movements and insist that she
kept her hair blonde and wear bikinis
and high heels at these shows she was
brown hair in the other picture
literally all that makes total sense to
me I don't understand well no first of
all okay you're married and you're
working in a business guess what you're
working at the business and sometimes
you're not booked in and all kinds of
[ __ ] yeah that happens to all of mine
yeah and then bringing porn into a
relationship if not don't and you if you
haven't done that what's wrong with you
yeah you're I feel like they're coming
up with [ __ ] to make him sound malicious
yeah but this is a clear case of you
don't [ __ ] up so the other money that
he also lost because of this affair was
that he had to spend more money on
household help child care and counseling
Oh cuz she left she left her daughter to
be based off of the child care note here
I'm assuming she left her kid too
because of that but I don't know further
the third bullet on the we got his ass
list is he introduced porn of the
relationship they got nothing on this
guy that's why he didn't feed the fishes
like gone two nights you went to bed
without feeding the fishes
so Danielle told her husband that she
was just so stressed out she would just
really wanted to have a spa weekend at
the beach for her birthday alone like
I'll have a peaceful week alone but yeah
I guess we tagged along this whole
taggle on so in the past he didn't know
he had no idea you know you didn't know
until men's and separate it no I don't
think they were even friends Oh Oh for
some reason I thought that you know he
was a part of that industry well that
these BMX shows I guess see what like
she would be one of the marketing people
yeah yeah so I mean I was
industry-related know with his company
okay oh yeah yeah yeah so yeah the judge
determined that holy [ __ ] this guy's a
good ass guy that's how much trustee had
cuz he was like yeah uh wife's Fran you
won't come down to vacation cool call
wait relationship cool he had no [ __ ]
clue
he didn't know that they didn't know she
did her own thing yeah he thought she
was alone he secretly came yes oh my god
okay
but he also how could tolling could it
be if his wife got this [ __ ]
apartment and didn't even know was going
on there he's not looking in the books
for that that's bold dude
eight million though what does that guy
do he's gonna forty-eight million looks
like he like fishes aquarium
I feel like eight millions not gonna fix
his broken heart you saw the way he
acted and he has a kid about it yeah and
his age like the the type of girls that
he's gonna find they're all gonna be
gold diggers give me he's got nine
million uh well cold diggers don't make
me happy though I bet you she was a gold
digger dude that's it was exactly what
happened find someone hotter and he'll
make her dye her hair blonde too I wear
high heels
uh hell yeah look at someone younger
dude I want to find some kind of dirt on
this guy so I feel better about
everything I agree I know it's sad cuz
hearing him screams crowd sad the worst
thing of all was he lost his sponsorship
for Monster energy drink because they
don't sponsor [ __ ] heard we don't
sponsor [ __ ] ass fools
[Music]